summer doesn't officially start for
another week but we are already
expecting record
breaking heat this afternoon we are
keeping an eye on those temperatures we
do have team coverage
starting with of course chief milo just
ted florendo but we also have bianca
holman and she has some warnings from
the national weather service
now so staying out of the sun and
staying hydrated is something we're used
to
living here in las vegas and in southern
nevada but experiencing these hot
temperatures for
several days well that's something we're
not used to we were able to check in
with the national weather service and
they say that there's nothing typical
about our temperatures this week there
are records that may be broken with
temperatures running 10 to 15 degrees
above normal
in 2013 a heat wave in southern nevada
had 30 fatalities and more than 350 heat
related injuries
this heat is serious and officials want
everyone to stay safe through this
extended heat wave
it's actually very unusual and one of
the questions we get a lot is
why do we worry about the heat it's the
summer in the desert that's true it does
get warmer at this time but not to this
fast and doesn't last this long
and we're talking about record
temperatures being broken not just in
one site we're talking about
over 40 different locations that might
be seeing record-breaking temperatures
and not for one day
possibly five six or even seven days so
this is
quite a bit uncommon this is not typical
desert southwest heat you might think
hitting the lake will cool you off but
that could be a dangerous situation as
well the water may be cooler but the
land around the lake is hotter than in
the city
you can easily experience hypothermia
heat stroke or heat exhaustion
and of course another reminder when it
comes to our vehicles they say put a
something
very important maybe like your purse or
your wallet in the back seat so that you
don't forget your child
or your pet heat related deaths are very
very serious
and they can happen in a matter of
minutes bianca holman
8 news now